Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dillon from
Massachusetts. Dillon, you're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: OK, perfect. I'm in my car. Let
me know if there's any background noise.
Speaker 1: You know there is, but we're
going to try to get get to the question.
Speaker 5: OK, so what if we were to see some
sort of national health care, try to bully and try
to be implemented? What sort of model would you
personally want to see it modeled after?
Speaker 1: Oh, that that's really tough. I mean,
here's the thing. There's so many models
that work. You have to start with your
priorities and then work backwards.
So universal access for me is a must.
Affordability for me is a must.
And when you prioritize those two,
it's conceivable that quality may not
be as high as you want. But obviously,
we want all three of these things, and it's kind
of like a push pull with which you've Reinhart
wrote about in his in his most recent book before
he passed away. So I think there is a lot to look
at in the German system. That's interesting.
I think the Nordic model is interesting.
You know, when people just say Medicare for all
and forget about it, there's no debate to be had.
I don't necessarily agree with that. I don't
think Medicare for All is a panacea. And
I think a lot of people who say Medicare for
All, they actually mean a number of different
configurations that that could be possible. But I
have a long clip on this, which looks at, I mean,
there's no one answer for me is the point. And
one key issue as well is my answer. If we were to
have one federal system might be different, then
if we say this would be done at the state level.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I mean, my personal opinion would
be look at Canada or look at Germany for like a
centralized versus a decentralized system.
Speaker 3: Yes, yes.
Speaker 1: I think that depending on a number
of different factors specific to each country,
there are merits to all of these different
systems, all of which are better than
the one we have in the United States.
Speaker 5: Interesting. How do you think
people would react to the government taking
a more intrusive interest in public health?
Speaker 1: I think we know the answer to that
part of the country would welcome it in part
of the country would say that it's fascism.
Speaker 5: Do you remember when Bill de Blasio
tried to ban certain like I think it
was one gallon or one liter jugs of
soda from being sold in convenience stores?
Speaker 1: Wasn't that Bloomberg? I don't.
I don't remember de Blasio doing
it. I remember Bloomberg doing it.
Speaker 5: Maybe it might have been.
I just remember it was interesting
to me because I thought of all places New
York City would be OK with these sorts of
things and it just did not go well at all.
Speaker 1: Well, one of the things about
that is you're kind of hurting. Sadly, you're
hurting the poorer people because typically,
you know, when you buy juice and soda, whatever in
larger quantity, you're paying less per ounce. So
when you say no more, 64 ounces is only thirty
two's. Usually buying 232 is is more expensive.
So there was a real argument to be made
that it was disproportionately hurting
poor people, which which is literally true.
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's fair. That's fair. I
just I just I see any sort of like efforts by the
government to make the public healthier is it's
just not going super well in the United States.
Speaker 1: But, you know, people
like to see people like Cass Sunstein say people
should be nudged rather than forced into making
those decisions. And there's a lot of behavioral
economics behind it, which many on the left
right off a centrist nonsense. But I think
there's there's a fair amount to be taken
from it. These are really, really important
topics which have a lot, a lot behind them,
and I appreciate you calling in about it.
Speaker 5: Thanks for taking it. Thank you
for taking the question, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. There is
Dylan from Massachusetts, an important
call on a number of important issues